- Thank you, thank you.
Hey, everybody.
I noticed that I am now
a Chief Product Office.
The r is missing.
Good to have everybody here.
We're gonna, the game plan
for the next 20 minutes
is I'm gonna talk about
Reltio, the company,
we're gonna talk about our product,
we're gonna talk about
all the amazing movement
that we're seeing by building
agents on top of data
that is within Reltio.
So what is Reltio?
Let's start with that.
Reltio is a data unification platform.
The idea behind data unification
is that for any company
of a reasonable size,
they will have plenty of
data about their customers,
their suppliers,
different products that they sell,
and this data ends up
being in different parts
of their organization,
whether it's in different SaaS products,
whether it's a different databases,
you know, you have product
data in a warehousing system,
you'll have product data in an
e-commerce system and so on.
So, how do you bring all of this together,
unify this data to produce a single view
of authoritative view
of any of these nouns
that matter for your system?
So, what Reltio does is it brings together
this multi-source data
and gives you a trusted single view
on which you can build
your business operations
at the highest level.
Yeah, our approach has been to,
we started with a space
that is called Master Data Management.
Raise your hands if you know
what Master Data Management is.
Ah, okay, fantastic.
So, the idea of Master Data Management
was to bring together
multiple different records
and really manufacture a
golden record out of that.
And this definition of golden record
was fairly narrow, right?
You were talking about the
definition of an individual,
where they live, their
contact details, and so on.
And as this space has evolved,
this idea has become
less of a golden record
and much more of a trusted profile,
which are these sort of
very rich descriptions
of customers or suppliers and so on,
which have detailed amount of information
drawn from many, many different sources.
And this graph representation
of these entities
is maintained up to the second,
and it's available for
consumption via an API
or via the real-time
systems all the time, right?
And so, it's an evergreen data foundation
that a lot of other
processes can be built on.
Where Reltio sort of,
the way we approached it at Reltio
is to think of all of this
as a relationship graph
and different entity
types, their relationships,
and including a 360 view
of all the behaviors
that might be associated
with these entities.
So, in simple terms,
if you're talking about a customer,
a customer has an address, they have,
they also have a purchase
history with you,
they have clickstream,
which they've used to,
or they've browsed your website,
and therefore they have a clickstream
associated with that and so on.
So this complete 360 view
in a way that is connected,
every entity is connected
to everything else,
that really is the heart
of what Reltio represents.
Now, what the story,
you can also already
see it coming is a graph
is a very natural data structure
for large language models
to interact with, right?
So, on the left-hand side,
you see many, many different
data sources that can be used
to bring data into Reltio.
But the interesting bit is
on your right-hand side,
where you see the ability
to consume this graph,
either through applications
or by sending it into
different data warehouses.
But most interestingly,
our customers are building
agents on top of this data.
And that's really been an
amazing experience to watch.
I'll give you two examples.
CarMax, the biggest retailer
of used cars in the United States.
What they use Reltio for
is that they've organized
the data into 360s.
Why?
Well, at the highest level,
the promise they have to their customers
is somebody can walk into a CarMax,
either buy or sell or buy and sell
and leave within 15 minutes,
so they have a transaction
business guarantee of 15 minutes.
How do they do that?
Well, to achieve that,
they have to organize,
by the way, they see a typical
vehicle in the United States
three times in the vehicle's lifetime.
Yeah, it's traded multiple times,
so it makes sense for
them to have a 360 view
of every vehicle they possibly can
so that they know as
much about that vehicle
as possible over time.
They also have a 360 view of prospects
or customers that they have
dealt with in the past,
and they have a 360 degree
view of their employees,
and for them, an transaction
is the combination of a vehicle,
a prospect or a customer,
and a salesperson who's made the sale
because their goal is not
just that the customer
can walk out within 15 minutes,
but also that they settle
with the salesperson
within that 15-minute window.
And the way to achieve
that business outcome
literally is to organize the data
that is friendly for that outcome, right?
And that's what's happening,
that's what they use Reltio for.
Now, a very, very different example,
completely different
industry, Warner Brothers.
Now, what is a product
for Warner Brothers?
It's their intellectual property,
are all the characters, right?
So if you're thinking
about "Looney Tunes,"
pick a character from "Looney Tunes,"
that particular character
has appeared in a certain
number of movies or cartoons,
they've appeared as merchandise
through different suppliers.
they have licensing agreements, right?
So, that is what constitutes
a 360 for Daffy Duck
or Roadrunner in this case, right?
And having that data be ready
to be then explored via
large language models,
that is what Warner Brothers uses us for.
So two very different examples,
but the point is the way
the data is organized
reduces the effort in
actually ingesting the data
and organizing the data,
and it makes the consumption of the data
is much more front and center, yeah?
So, if we think about this space,
bringing together data from
multiple different sources
and assembling it together,
this problem has been a problem
ever since we've had multiple SaaS systems
or multiple databases, right,
this data fragmentation problem.
And at the core of what
we're trying to solve for
is we were saying,
there's two or three or four
records that all indicate,
or they're all related to the
same individual, let's say.
How can we pick and choose
and connect these records
so that we have as much of a trusted view
of this customer as possible, right?
You're using first-party data,
you're also bringing in
third-party data to enrich
and get the output of this process
to be as high quality as possible, yeah?
But it's not all automated yet.
Even in 2020, let's say 2024, 2023,
there was still a lot of
manual effort being put in.
And if you think about
the larger the company,
the more the manual effort
in trying to make sure
that the data stewards,
that's the particular role,
data stewards are spending a lot of effort
making sure that the data is
as high quality as possible.
Now, of course, data quality itself
is a very interesting topic of discussion
because you can spend a lot of money
getting data quality the
highest level possible.
And the ROI on that,
it is really determined
by what is the application
of that particular data, right?
So data quality has to be
mapped to the business outcome
that that quality is looking for.
And so how much effort
you put into data quality
is sort of the second piece
that's been sometimes highly manual
and sometimes very expensive, yeah?
And the third thing is
complex data models,
as I described,
this space is about bringing together
different data models or data
from different data models
and combining it together
so that you have authoritative view
of that particular entity.
And there's complexity
in being able to map all these together,
and typically that's been done
from a manual point of view, right?
So these are the real problems.
If you think about,
you know, you say it's very easy to say,
"If you have your data organized well,
agents are going to behave well,"
or, "Trusted data leads to trusted AI."
But the how part is left
unsaid a lot of times, right?
And this approach that I'm
going to share with you
really goes to the heart of that how.
It's a very pragmatic approach
to how to get trusted agents.
And so the goal that we set out on
is really to take this manual effort
in organizing this data
down by an order of magnitude
or two orders of magnitude,
automate as much of that as possible.
So here's what I'm gonna walk you through,
I'm gonna walk you
through a couple of demos
pretty quick here,
but just to orient you on our product set.
So at the base,
everything runs on a unified data cloud,
Reltio Data Cloud
that any of the products
that run on top of the data
cloud inherit the scalability
and the security aspects
that are built on top of AWS.
The two products that
we offered a year ago
are our multi-domain MDM and
our Intelligent 360 products.
And the way to think about it
is that multi-domain MDM
encapsulates everything that has to do
with entity information.
And then if you add behaviors,
if you wrap that around
to build a true 360 in real time,
that's the Intelligent 360 product.
And what we're gonna talk about today
is really the agents that the agent flow,
which is the layer on top
of these two capabilities
that delivers fully functional
agents in two regards.
The first agent,
and I'm gonna show you a demo of both,
the first type of agent,
class of agent is for
managing data itself.
So the data that's in the graph
that exists within MDM or
within Intelligent 360,
how can we manage that autonomously?
I'll show you an example of that.
And the second example is
once the data is managed
as pristine of a state as you can make it,
let's put it to use, right?
So how do you build an
application effectively
or an agent that's partially
doing what a CRM would do
or a a customer success system would do,
but do that as an application
that's built on top of data?
And this is sort of the
data-first application movement
that's very much in play right now, yeah?
So let's look at the first scenario.
In this case, we are trying to solve
for data management,
we're trying to solve for duplicate data,
and here we go.
So, as you see, it's a
conversational interface.
There's really no mention of data,
yeah, anywhere in terms
of the interface itself,
and we're just asking a business question.
We're saying, "Hey, we're
seeing service delays
in our top 100 segment
and we suspect that there is some
data duplication going on."
So, the system at that point,
our agent is looking at
what does that top 100 mean?
And it's getting that definition
from the underlying data platform,
and it's able to then propose an approach
where it says, "I found what
that top 100 means for that,
each organization, I'm
gonna systematically look at
why that duplication is happening."
Yeah, and it says
it gives you a simple option you can pick,
you know, as these,
I'm sure everybody's very familiar
with these sort of
interfaces at this point,
and it's identified that
there are two organizations
that actually have some
duplication in the data.
And then further it says,
it proposes a couple of actions
that are proposed for each one of those.
And it'll show us that
for this particular
organization, Solar Turbines,
there are, it goes attribute by attribute
and says, "Okay, well, I'm
looking at two versions
of information about this organization,
and I can see that there
are some mismatches
that are probably causing, you know,
for example, suboptimal shipping,
like you're shipping to the
wrong location and so on."
And so we say, "Okay."
By the way, it's also enriched this data
by looking up the internet, right?
That's one of the requests
we've always had from customers.
There's such a rich and
ever updated source of data,
the internet,
why can't that be brought in
to the data management platform?
And so it's sort of done all of that.
It's broadened this data
and it's created this level of automation
where if somebody had
to go and look this up,
they would very easily take 35-40 minutes
to go resolve this.
A data steward would very easily spend
30 minutes resolving this.
And so this took less
than a minute, right?
So just the savings in terms of doing
100 of these a day,
that's pretty enormous.
And of course, needless to say,
the whole thing can be automated, right?
It doesn't have to be conversational.
Everything is API driven,
so you can very easily wrap this up
in an even next level of automation.
The next demo I'm gonna show you
is around is more on that
next level of building,
being able to build applications
given that that data is already organized
in a proper manner.
And in this demo what we're showing
is there's customer data
and there's product data,
and a call is coming in from a customer
and our agent intends to show
the next-best product recommendation
or at least propose that to the agent
that so that they can
talk to the customer.
Of course, there's no assumption
whether it's a human agent
on this side of the phone
or an AI,
it doesn't really matter.
The point is, can we
produce a recommendation
down to the personalization of one, right?
If given as much data as
we have about the customer
and their past behavior,
can we actually build something
that is very, very customized for them?
So, very similar to the previous demo,
we'll drop into the
conversational interface.
And in this case, the
question we're asking is,
for a certain customer, we
provided a name Sarah Anne,
and please provide three
compelling product recommendations
and base that on her profile
and different relationships
that we see in the system
and different interactions
that they've had with us.
And so the system's looking for,
searching for that individual
and it finds a perfect match there.
And it's going through our MCP layer
and talking to our API, in this case.
And it says, "We found
a unique individual,
here's some information about them.
They're 46-year-old married female
from San Francisco, et cetera."
And we're seeing from them
that they have purchased from us recently,
there's a pattern there.
They're actually an enthusiast.
They interact with our blog
or some of our content.
And here is a set of recommendations
that she would most
likely be interested in.
And the thing on the left
is not interesting to me,
the thing on the right is more interesting
because that is the why.
Why is the agent
recommending certain things?
Yeah, because at the end of the day,
we have to be able to defend our decisions
to present something to a customer, right?
So, we go a step further,
we say, "This is great,
but if you look at the household,
perhaps she's interested
in buying something
for her household, somebody else,
a gift for somebody else,
not just something for herself,
so what would you recommend in that case?"
And so we look at
sort of the next surrounding circle
level in the tree,
and we find that the family
consists of Michael, Olympia and Sarah.
And Olympia, who's the daughter,
we have consent from her,
she's expressed consent
for new product launches.
So we could potentially position something
for Sarah in this case, right?
And the system goes through and says,
"For Olympia and Michael, in this case,
there is a specific kit
that we're recommending,"
and then the rationale
on the right-hand side
says why we're making
that recommendation, yeah?
It also, it'll scroll here in a second,
and to me what's interesting
is also the suggestion to the agent
who's having the conversation.
There's a communication strategy, right?
It is about how to present,
not just what to present,
but how to present this.
And that's based on a
certain amount of data
that's already in the system,
behavior that we've seen in the past.
And we'll actually ask the agent,
we'll say, "How much did you consider?
How much data did you consider?
How many data points did you consider
while making these recommendations?"
And it'll come up with an answer.
And in this case,
I think it's used 70 plus data points
from multiple different,
11 different sources and
multiple interactions
that it's had access to in the past.
And so what this shows you
is if you have data
organized a certain way,
then using agentic AI on top of that
almost seems simple and magical.
Conversely, think about
what you would have to do
if you're trying to create an agent
that is delivering you this outcome,
but your data is distributed
in five different databases,
multiple applications, right?
You'd be stitching together
all this information
when you need it,
and that becomes a very
expensive operation.
It becomes a very,
the outcomes become harder to predict
because on the other hand,
there's a customer, you're
trying to solve that problem
or present a proposal for the customer
and your system is busy sort of assembling
all this information together.
Yeah, so that, to me
is the real power of a
data unification system
where you have a graph ready
to consumed at all times
and you're not really spending
any engineering resources.
Once you've set up the graph,
it's ready to go at all times.
So a little bit about how we built this,
of course, we are powered
by AWS technology,
so we were one of the
earliest users of AgentCore
and the Strands,
Strands SDK.
So, the core of the agent
is built out using Strands
and for us, AgentCore,
as it has developed,
it's become really this sort
of super easy way to scale up
and not have to worry about
a lot of the non-functional aspects
or have to worry about
whether we'll have security taken care of
or access to memory so we
don't have to assemble memory
and web access, tooling and all that.
That kind of comes as a package,
and we can focus on really the value
that we are creating on top of that.
In a sense, the model
used doesn't really matter
because all these models are so capable.
I think as an ISV for us to create this,
it really is about getting
those non-functional aspects
to be testable.
Because today if you're using Model X,
tomorrow it'll be Model X+1
and how to make sure that we're able
to actually give you the
same performance at scale.
Because remember, the customers,
our customers are some
of the largest companies
in the world.
And so the ability to operate at scale
and yet go from one version of a model
to the next version of a model
and guarantee no regressions,
that's the sort of important thing
that a solution like
AgentCore provides us, right?
So we are very excited about
some of the policy-related announcements
that were made yesterday,
and really looking
forward to incorporating
some of that into the mix.
With that, I've shown
you a bunch of videos,
if you want to see the
real thing in action,
we are at both 1227.
I'll be there for a little bit,
happy to talk,
but the Reltio team is there,
and we'd love to take questions there.
Really appreciate everybody's time.
Look forward to seeing you.